Zed the legendary assassin that used to
be the one shot King never the strongest
meta pick but still incredibly dangerous
in the right hands at the right time now
though he's currently being banned in
one in every three games of League of
Legends some people feel he is an
absolute monster here's
[Music]
why all right so Zed is not in the
healthiest spot in League of Legends
right now
what did I just die
to what the is that for most of Zed's
11-year history he's been a solo qu hero
a niche pick popular in low ELO with
huge snowball potential but
traditionally if that snowball doesn't
get going in the early game it's hard
for him to succeed this has always been
especially true in higher ranks and pro
play where players have been more able
to play around his cooldowns and punish
him but recently his ban rates have
spiked to over 30% in Masters and over
36% in Bronze in fact across all ranks
his ban rate is now pushing 40% making
him the second most banned champion in
the game behind the recently released
Brier so what has changed why has he now
struck fear into the hearts of the legal
virgins Community after being fairly
inconsequential for so many years the
answer is ability haste so far in season
13 Riot have made some pretty sweeping
changes to Assassin items we've seen
Nerfs Buffs and reworks but when the
dust settled assassin players realized
that stacking ability haste was actually
more optimal than some traditional build
paths Hydra dusk blade Black Cleaver
serala Axiom and Boots can result in
ridiculous ability haste levels which
have created a perfect storm in a
champion like Zed ability haste paired
with W Max on Zed has resulted in living
Shadow becoming a borderline spammable
ability with much lower downtime than in
past Seasons all of this has contributed
to zed feeling more like a mage than an
assassin able to safely clear waves at a
distance in the laning phase and become
incredibly slippery by the mid game to
put it simply many feel that the state
of ability haste on Zed has made him non
interactive and remove the highrisk high
reward gameplay that made him the poster
child for a assassins in League one
redditor ran the numbers recently to
point out that with just two items and
boots they hit 44% cooldown reduction
beyond what the CDR cap used to be and
that they hit 61% with their full build
able to just Spam W's at will now to put
that in perspective Earth mode gives you
75% cooldown reduction so we're not a
million miles off that but here's the
thing in some ways all of this is no
accident in a recent tweet riot fron
said they've been trying to move certain
classes away from damage and into other
outputs EG assassins using haste instead
of damage to make them more about
repeatability and less about
one-shotting he later said that
Champions casting more abilities is what
they've been leaning towards because it
channels their game playay through their
kits but is this actually what people
want from assassins one reditor argue
that they don't mind when Zed one- shots
them but it all comes down to a lack of
counterplay and Tra offs that it's fine
if assassins one-hot people because they
traditionally have long cool downs and
have to wait for another attempt if they
fail to get the kill the argument here
is that one- shotting is the whole point
of Assassins that's kind of their shtick
the issue is they've been building High
ability hay sustain Bruiser items like
Gore Drinker Black Cleaver and ravenous
Hydra which have turned them more into
ad Mages fron weighed in again to
explain that Riot balances assassins
around three different types of combos
their luxury ones which are ideal but
infrequent their standard ones which are
easier to pull off and their low
counterplay ones which should rarely
result in a kill the issue froon says is
that assassins have had to rely on
Landing their perfect luxury combo to
even have a chance of getting a kill
because there's too much counterplay for
their squishy targets to avoid or
disrupt a combo he also said that
ability haste has been used to avoid one
shot or be one shot metas which allows
assassins to lean more on their utility
spells and ultimates when behind so they
don't need to be so overbearing when
ahead to avoid the agency and
counterplay issues associated with this
he pointed to dust blade being an
example of an item which with no haste
and more ad to compensate would be
difficult to tune with those standard
combos because every item will cause
such a spike in burst damage he did
acknowledge that assassins building Gore
Drinker is not ideal but that they do
consider some like Black Cleaver to be
healthy when used situationally fron
also admitted that the downside of using
non damage stats like haste to balance
around is that people will complain
about Zed builds but that he thinks this
is specifically a zed issue and one
which they're looking into and this is
something that some in the community
have been saying that this isn't an
assassin problem it's a zed problem that
his standard combo has more range than
some Mages and that his mobility and
safety simply does not have a proper
tradeoff versus his damage assassins are
admittedly having a bit of an identity
crisis right now but Zed has become the
face of this because his issues are so
egregious they've actually shifted him
into an entirely different class of
Champions sure other assassins may have
issues around ability haste and
counterplay but at least they're still
assassins and that's more than you can
say for Zed at times now there has also
been some clapback to the complaining
one parody post on Reddit argue that Zed
should just lose damage every time he
builds an item and that he shouldn't
have Mobility like an assassin another
featured interviews from three victims
of Zed abuse with his crimes including
farming under his Tower it's fair to say
there isn't complete consensus on this
some people feel this is just the normal
complaint from players who believe that
any Champion that counters their own
shouldn't be in the game but as we've
seen from this video and the recent ban
rates many do feel that Zed is is part
of a deeper issue here that while he may
not be the devil incarnate he is a
microcosm of a much larger issue the
13.20 patch preview was released
yesterday which features an incoming
Nerf to ZW in an attempt to steer
players towards maxing his e instead and
ultimately make him less magy they admit
that this is simply a Band-Aid fix for
now while we may see his band rate slide
back to normal levels until there's a
fundamental rework of Z relationship
with the items that he relies on we may
continue to see The Zed problem bubble
just under the
surface